what is happening there citizens of the reject
Nation we are here to watch the final episode
of Hot D House of the Dragon John how are you I
am hot and excited for some more D so ladies and
gentlemen for those who have been watching with
us I want to say thank you from the bottom of
my heart if you can go ahead strike that like
button strike it down that mean the world to
us right now also um as always falling stretch
and watch along's resync with your own copy for
how to the dragon I tried that available for
a super section rejects over at our patreon
page your support has been overwhelming and
one of the best ways is support the channel
is to check out some of our apparel I'm much
as we like to call it some of you guys might
not know this we partnered up with a screen
crush and heavy spoilers who right now has a
video up that I'm sure has 1.4 million views
in the last half hour for House of the dream
um he's absolutely killing it these days and
we partnered up with our shop there right now
heavy spoilers he's got a shirt for House of
the Dragon representing Team Green but real
rejects we got one representing team black
that's right look he's already getting all
the views so go support us we're gonna get our
shirt now we might not have that shirt in hand
right now because we're Masters at promoting our
own products we just launched it this week and we
don't but you know what maybe we'll all get one
time here's here's a photo of a hot guy wearing
it look at him wearing it but any gender can wear
it so yeah guys shop zeroedition.com anyway let's
watch the final episode now all right that's what
we really want to do let's see what's going on
not like you in what way not so
perfect she's not perfect I've heard it described
in the book that she is way worse my father
looked after me and helped to prepare me for my
duties oh my God it's come to deliver a message
ready for battle Bucyrus is dead
your father possessed a kind heart
wow so much has happened I forgot she
didn't even know that yeah Egon has been
crowned as his successor how did viserys die
I could not say so soft-spoken that [__]
of a queen murdered my brother and stole his
throne and you could have burnt little friend
that war is not mine to begin I only
rushed this morning to you out of
loyalty to my husband and to my house
the greens are coming for you rhaenyra
oh [__] we should leave Dragonstone at
once yeah okay ever the conscientious one
oh no blood is coming of course our term is far
from complete this should not be happening it is
happening stress you know we're
kind of get up get up get up
this show definitely makes birth
seem like the most horrific thing
conscript the dragon Keepers they're capable
Fighters waste no time it will be done my prince
I hope everyone here remains loyal to you there's
got to be a spy in there somewhere what's this to
be done about it nothing yet where is Damon I
don't know gone to Madness gone to plot his War
but leave them with me wow my pulse are so up
the knuckles are white my mother has decreed
no action be taken while she's in bed
it's good you're here Young Prince did
you hear what I said the Ravens looked at
this I shall see it done yeah
I'd lose I'd listen to demon
come with me I'll show you
the true meaning of loyalty oh
I'm grateful for your long service to the
crown so I'm presenting you with a choice
let's do a little mutiny
huh
what's the choice oh you knew you're
out to Rainier as your queen yep oh
if you support yourself speaker now
if you swear fealty now only to later turn
your cloaks huh know that you will die
I was gonna say it looks like
no one's able to do anything
what the hell wow
oh oh my God
oh how horrible
Jesus Christ
there's a lot yeah
foreign
just seems awful whenever you see this guy around
for a pregnancy he's like pregnancy of any kind in
this world is a kind of an awful experience
no matter what did the whole thing herself
bag
that's really that's really brutal and
I can't believe they showed that much
interesting how the first episode
started off with her mother
having a failed delivery here we are bookending it
seems like the beginning middle and end even
have all been marked by bitter pregnancies
Eric or Eric
I swear toward the queen I
shall take no wife hold no lands
father no children I shall guard her Secrets
ride at her side and defend her name and honor
I mean she needed a significant moment wow
come on Iranians bend the knee come on
damn a hell of a shot
this feels almost like Lucid it's like
you're so steeped in all the emotion
and the literal weight of the crown
it fell that is very beautiful let's
say I gotta get a hunk of wood and
some candles and build me one of
those you can buy one from Kmart
thank you
thank you Reina wouldn't hurt to mix
up the names George armor you know
loses a baby immediately gets to work yo of course
owns a power that has not been seen in this world
since the days of old valyria dragons none of our
dragons have been to war there are also unclaimed
dragons she smokes still resides on driftmark
oh [__] Dragonstone has 13 to therefore
I also have a score of eggs incubating
in the dragon Mound and we could have
every green head mounted on
spikes before the Moon Turns
along gallium flying a banner
of a three-headed Green Dragon
although the watchtowers inside the skies
dude Damon is ready he's been waiting for this
it's just gone all in the hyper Focus mode yeah
here we are again a little jittery there Damon
a lot of mirroring happening this episode it
Rhymes I come at the behest of The Dowager Queen
Alice Lord and protector of the Seven Kingdoms
where is the princess
really calling back cheese
acknowledge aegon as king and swear a basins
before the iron throat hell no it says Grace
will confirm your possession of Dragonstone
viserys will be confirmed as the legitimate
air to drift Mark and all the lands and holdings
of house valarian we'll also be given places of
high honor at court this guy's such a dick
rather feed my sons to the dragons and have
them carry Shields and cups for your drunken new
Serpent of a king yeah he was anointed by a septum
of the faith before the eyes of thousands
every symbol of legitimacy belongs to him
oh my auto God you own him more hand
than egg of his King concentrator
Grand maester
is this
you're talking like so modern in this
episode enough of the [__] yeah cut
the crap high tower Queen Alison has not
forgotten the love you once had for each
other no plant need to be spilled
the realm can carry on in peace
Queen Alison deeply awaits your answer
she could have her answer now stopped
in her father's mouth along with his
withered let's send this mum as far
no come on
yes Queen King's Landing will
have my answer on the moon
dropping bombs when dragons flew to war everything
burned I do not wish to rule over a kingdom of
Ash and Bone yeah good boy father talking my
father's dead and he chose me as his successor
to defend the realm not cast it headlong
into the enemy have declared war
what are you going to do about it
I mean
she's like a spirit that's just haunting I know
she exists Beyond everything have fun guys my oath
reaches beyond our personal Ambitions A Song of
Ice and Fire the coming war against the darkness
in the north a conquerors dream if Sarah shared it
with me when he named to me no dude my brother was
a slave to his Island's importance oh anything
to make his feckless man appear tough purpose
dreams didn't make us Kings
too far man yeah we gotta unpack that bro
I never told you
oh wow ouch I mean what do you have to
know I guess no what do you have to know
yeah never consider him to be one to inherit the
throne or maybe Damon thought like he would be
I mean no he did he lives he
lives his fever has broken
I understand you have a new king no right
to business everyone wait wait for No One
in our son's death that girl destroys
everything she touches that girl is
holding the round together at present wow we're
nearest the only one who's demonstrated restraint
an unlikely Alliance they both
got poised look always felaria it
wow very sorry about your
father princess he's a good man
and I your brother
where is Damon there are other concerns which
demanded the prince's attention he didn't want
an awkward conversation he's much happier playing
with his dragons both Aaron and Baratheon share
blood with my house but all of them swore
Oaths to me as did house Hightower as did you
yeah yeah yeah I did I'm gonna go lay down
again this high tower treason cannot stand
you have the full support of
our Fleet oh my God oh my God
I turn real quick on that chat save up money for
season two we got some battles to
get to uh consult a gold company
could have killed aegon
caution does not mean standing fast I wish to
know who my allies are before I send them to war
now she's playing a smart man yeah consequence
of my near demise in the stepstones is that we
now control them I took care to fully Garrison
the territory this time oh the triarchy had
been routed the narrow sea is ours in that grip I
should take me Elise and Patrol the gullet myself
are we going to war baby we're going
to war we should bear those mistress
dragons can fly faster than Ravens and then
more convincing yeah intimidate them and to
agree that always works Prince is right your grace
it's the cast of avatar The Last Airbender
let's take no part in any
fighting swear it to me no
under the eyes of the seven I
swear I will not kill anyone
I would hope that as men you can find some common
interest yes as men as half black blonde men yeah
always looks so unsure of yourself
man go to it then chop chop
this is the first episode with like like
motivating music yeah yeah yeah we gotta
reach further than we've ever dreamed before
all right that's beautiful it's like Avatar
the James Cameron movie every Avatar well
and this one it's it's funny this is the
most like all the ways they capture the
castle of Dragonstone it really does look
like a big dragon curled up and especially when
they're having like meeting it's so intimidating
it looks like he's trying to get more dragons how
many dragons at once could he have loyal to him
wow wow nice beautiful
psychic connection Halloween ends
I've seen everyone you've ever dracar East
you've got this hiccup
I'm real afraid one of these kids are gonna
die yeah I feel like this kid's about to die
I think they're gonna kill that dragon foreign
monster movie right here
this kid's a goat in the T-Rex pen I'll
bring a message to Lord Boris from the queen
okay that's fine that's fine had
a feeling man yeah Don't Do It
Eamon oh so the tracker does
not seem to know who rules it
Jesus
he's so good at that stair Eamon
he's gonna like charge him or some [__]
yeah he's gonna slice his head in half or
something if I do with your mother which one of
my daughters will you win I'm already betrothed
so you come with empty hands I shall
take your answer to the queen my Lord
wait what what what I came as a messenger
not a warrior I promised my mom fight would
be a little challenge I want
you to put out your eye wow
I would not blind you I plan to
make a gift of it to my mother oh
she's gonna love that then you are craving as
well as a traitor not here get me all right
I'll not have blood shape beneath my roof take
princess back to his dragon oh this ain't over
better hurry up and get away
man [__] [__] [__] [__]
oh I think amen's gonna find him in the sky or
some [__] yeah most definitely he
only said no Bloodshed under my roof
don't stand around dude just get out of
there oh no oh no sorry for this dragon
[__] just waiting for an appear man
it's like every one of these
clouds is that it is not smart man
get above it
there it is
oh still oh he's just laughing maniacally
wow oh my God
the size to your advantage
this is kind of crazy we're doing this until
this looks amazing but [__] this is scary
no I'm I'm so tense right now
he's saying Vegas too big yeah I was gonna
say I use that size to your advantage
you can hide and do faster maneuvers
oh [__] dude oh
oh no oh what is about to happen
oh
God it must be so cold up there
oh [__] oh wow
oh wow foreign
that was wild yeah I was and they
had no control over their trash
Damon's returning huh what did he
do did he did he gain some of the
feral dragons or something I think he's
given the message about what happened
this poor woman man poor dragon
oh what's this look gonna be
yeah right into your soul oh
holy [__] wow huh
it's a great last shot
that's crazy yeah hmm
what's really important is you guys
buy a shopzeroedition.com get your
support in for team black now you did
team black now in order for us to win
this war we gotta crush the greens yeah if
you haven't read the I don't know what's
I'm like damn all this happened in that book
all this and more is always the impression
I get all this but way more messed up wow
we got some [__] to talk about boy howdy
all right guys so in between cuts as I heard there
is so much I because of this episode you know
there's a little leak happened so I heard book
readers really did not like this episode a lot
obviously I didn't know specifics as to
why because I was like well if you can't
tell me because we gotta react to the
episode so in between cuts I was like
I really like this episode uh I mean I got like I
got like some some things that I thought were like
why didn't we talk about this yeah is there some
some points that I like we probably should have
had more of a discussion on on these things you
know the baby the dragon flashes while the baby
is happening parts of the baby will kind of look
like a dragon yeah we could spend a little more
time in the morning yeah there's everybody
that first found that yeah there were some
conversations that I was like you know but still
thought it was a great episode yeah it was gripped
the entire time so uh as I'm so I was like all
right I want to look up because I'm like like
crazy like am I wrong like what's my enjoyment
wrong and it sounds I mean there are things about
the way the handling of the characters are that
seems to have really pissed off some people
I don't know everything obviously because we
didn't read the book but uh we do have a shirt
representing the book team black from a book that
I've heard really inspires people to pick teams
um yeah I heard the see I thought the aiming
moment as someone who's all we can come from
is like I gotta just kind of throw all
that away anything I just learned in
the past couple minutes I kind of just got
to throw all that away and just talk about
um how we felt about the episode itself because
that matters like we didn't read the book so you
know like I'm not gonna be bothered by certain
things other than things that I thought on a
filmmaking writing poem like this should have been
done a little better but for the most part I still
thought it was great but yeah that one of the
ending one of the ending moment Parts is the thing
that clearly is upsetting people looking online of
uh like uh Veigar Vegas would be there right yeah
it's right there yes there you go Vega
and Eric's yeah there you go um so vegar
all week two three hours of sleep guys
my memory is going to be lapsing a lot
more during this discussion of
course gonna happen during the
House of the Dragon finale but yeah I think the
thing that people was uh pretty upsetting with
people is also the fact that Eamon didn't directly
kill yeah that it was like he lost control of the
Dragon yeah it becomes there's a lot apparently
that they that they have the handling of the
characters that they did differently that have
really upsetting people but that's like one of
the last things I read but I don't know I I
I guess like sure it can undercut some of the
you know the ruthlessness and determination and
the and perhaps it can lend a little bit more
to a situation of next season of him being like
it was an accident I don't know a lot of looked
pretty intentional for most of it and then it
was like oh [__] no didn't want to go that
far it's like when the bully's bullying someone
and it's like I didn't mean to kill him yeah
the ledge or something and
oh there goes their spine
um yeah or they got eaten yeah yeah because uh
so far this whole season a lot of it has been
feeling like a lot of things that have turning
points feel like misunderstandings but in terms
of the episode itself I was gripped by it uh
I like the Lucid quality to it and I like the
the mournful side that also had this
like uh inspiring angle to it and I think
yep it's already happening what is
the actress's name who plays renira
darson Emma Darcy I think Emma Darcy has a
wonderful internalized performance where I
could feel there's a lot more thought processing
happening in arguments and conversations then
she's probably letting on sure and I really
I really like the the pulse of the way the
hostility within characters was Rising because
you would have like Damon who after learning of
the death has become you know his way of grieving
with this is Revenge they've wronged me they've
wronged us they've wronged the family they've
killed my brother and he's just becoming a bull
bulldog about it and he's going straight into it
but you know he's also trying to honor reynera
but there's a there's a battle of of the Soul here
because it doesn't feel like what rhaenero wants
because he wants to just go in like let's
let's murder let's annihilate let's get all
these dragons together let's just F everyone
up and she's trying to take a more calculated
approach as raining said showing resistance and
I like that that tug of because you obviously
Rainier wants to take action but it's a
very much like the the speed of them like
is at odds with each other in the battle and
the approach and how it's tearing them apart
I was surprised by it man like I The Game of
Thrones World dealing with audiences is rough
could be a rough Journey for people I understand
I understand then all I think we can do is go how
did we feel about this on its own I do think some
stuff should have been uh talked about a little
bit more like she lost a baby in a very brutal
way they had these inner splicing moments with
the dragon and I didn't quite know what to make
of it there were parts of the baby that look like
dragon scale someone was pointing that out to me
and or someone was pointed out to everyone who
will listen and I I was like yeah but I thought
it could it just kind of looked like a a dead baby
like that that was born too early prematurely yeah
it didn't it didn't read explicitly at the time in
the moment as if the baby was like a hybrid of
any kind but then they could cut him back to the
dragon yeah so I didn't know I thought there was
more of an emotional thing they were doing some
type of like the Dragon one in her but well and
you know like the the obvious symbolism of like a
a mouth but then cutting to a scaled up mouth with
gnarled teeth during a moment such as birth where
you know I feel like there's a pretty obvious
kind of visual spiritual metaphor you can draw
especially in a birth as hostile and harsh as this
one is portrayed but they we didn't do any real
talking about it afterwards uh like no real
like we had a scene where they grieved about
it because that was such a harsh brutal like that
was that was you know wow that is like that that
was the I've had two pregnancy scenes in this in
this like I'm I'm not a woman and that was hard
for me as a man it was a guy just observing
like this is really hard for me to watch oh
sure like the first episode in this like it is
such they are both very hard scenes and this
one also was just very hard and she lost a baby
like she she lost a child and we're not really
no one's no one really talks about it yeah and I
mean you again I think you could argue that part
of that has to do in the immediate moment it feels
sort of like okay it's the compounding effect of
her being so internalized and having to exert so
much Poise because she knows she's surrounded by
people who are quick to action and you know maybe
slow to thought but at the same time it feels like
what's been made of her children and their
lineage and the fact that this is a child
with Daemon I feel like there would be a more
pointed yeah emotional response between the two
of them and again I guess you could argue that
they both close off and go do their own things
when they're grieving but at the same time that
and and viserys there are lots of Great Moments
officers no and there are great moments that that
ring that Bell to a degree and touch on those
relationships well I think just the interruption
sorry sorry you know I'm not a big fan of that
um is is like I think the The Grieving of
viserys is shown through Damon's performance
the whole time it is it is and and
I already nourish yourself you know
yeah yeah and I feel like that's a place where
I could have used maybe another scene either
good or or bad catharsis in terms of especially
with them touching on this idea that you know
viserys clearly he he showed his true error the
the prophecy The Song of Ice and Fire and Damon
is clearly hurt by that but but one thing that's
made Damon's character so interesting is that
frequently he will show that as Reckless as he
is as much as he doesn't care about how much of
a detriment he can be to his family he still very
much loves and cares for his brother especially
and so yeah like because that casts such a Paul
and you have all the political stuff that it sets
in motion but because of like the last time they
all saw him and these circumstances like yeah I
think the episode in the moment does a good job
of sweeping you up into the like well we need
to act like the machine is is running now like
you know we there's no time for these emotions
and and yet I think yeah yeah if I one of the
few gripes I would Levy in an episode like this
is that yeah like especially because the portrayal
of visceras and it's funny that people have had so
many problems with the portrayal of the characters
but unless he's just you know marketing for HBO
like George RR Martin was like yeah you're like
this is better than my character like I loved
your take on this character and he has been
a character that you know has been a a very
big highlight is a weird word because he's had
a really harsh Journey but he's a highlight of
the series and so you would I think expect for
the ending of the season and for you know he
will be remembered in the seasons to come
but this is the time to pay tribute to him
at the end of the you know this part of the
story and so I feel like yeah we could have
used an emotional unpacking or discussion or
something about him from them specifically
um or somebody like Otto Hightower could have also
mentioned like I get why he doesn't but somebody
could have mentioned like oh yeah and by the way
he changed his mind on his death bet like we could
have also had that conversation yeah because
people clearly will talk about that at King's
Landing you know I mean there's a whole lot of
big chunks dedicated to that in the last episode
I guess one part of me because it's like yeah
in the moment I I actually was thinking that I'm
like are you gonna mention this and then the other
part of me was like is there a point in mentioning
like would that do anything would they believe
you know it the only thing I could see it's it's
one of those like I feel like he could use it as
some kind of uh you know uh mind screw basically
to sort of suggest that even though I'm sure
she probably wouldn't be inclined to believe
it but suggested well this is what he said as he
was dying you know like you know that that could
at least be a mental manipulation mind you know
land mine tactic or something but at the same
time one thing the season seems out to do and
one thing I think makes sense too in character
is like no we're not gonna [__] fit around this
we're going to you know again we've already taken
action and you know and this was my plan all
along like I always recognize this guy as the
true air all along and you know that so I'm not
gonna BS you look guys while I haven't read the
book I think I know exactly how this is going to
end this whole show everyone's gonna be dead it's
just going to be Allison and renera on the beach
and they are just bleeding out and they are they
have both have knives in their hands she's got
the Song of Ice and Fire dagger and and then
you know like when it's when renera gets the final
steps you know they're slowly dying it's like they
get that you found like yeah yeah but I still
respect you [__] and uh and then she's like
what were my what were my father's last words
like she says that and then um she quotes his
last words and then they're like you mean to
tell me this is all just a big misunderstanding
what that's the thing too that I that there have
definitely been some significant complaints about
and I've this is like if this just got out to them
like what exactly was said in that room I feel
like that should maybe not exactly like that but I
feel like that ought to happen because I feel I I
understand that in the in the book it is different
and a lot of things happened intentionally because
here in this episode it's an accident the way
luceris died uh and you know this whole thing
with uh aegon has been escalated because of an
accident and and to me as a viewer of the show
in isolation that has felt like a theme a sort of
you know these big plans in this these prophecies
and this you know this Game of Thrones is all
human and it's all based on perspectives and
and what messages are going where and sometimes
the you know it's a sometimes there's a game
of telephone and sometimes people just mistake
stuff and then that's the history now and so like
I appreciate that as an idea as a theme and
I have enjoyed it here and I have sort of
uh uh you know I chalk that moment with you
know viserys you know yeah spouting out the
pieces of the prophecy thinking he's talking to
ramira as part of that but I can also see why
that doesn't feel as satisfying as like a much
more smart and deliberate choice I guess sure
as it sounds like the book does instead of some
of these things I don't know out of town we get
involved with the discourse I find it fun I've
found it interesting to hear what book readers
say because I respect it I can't I would never be
like hey it's different you know different medium
because I've had that with my own experiences
with other properties like it can be hard to
divorce yourself from it and and feel like it's
I think that the thing is like what if it's doing
it on both levels like okay it's an insult to
the source of the book and then it's also it's
also like contradicting or undermining things that
came before in the actual show you know yeah like
that's what I think like okay and I got a real
problem you know um because yeah it's like that
I love I love the I love it a lot about it you
know like rain is kind of just cracked me up in
this episode God just give her the throne please
Spirit walking around observing she's like it's
not my War but I'm gonna kick it here because I'm
literally kind of leaning here um so I'm a very
subconscious level I'm very much leaning towards
joining her side and that's why I didn't murder
them last episode but I keep sticking around
and even when uh uh oh Micah Corliss uh wakes
up first thing I'm gonna start doing has been
like you know she's actually giving her [__]
together real well yeah maybe we should have
learned I got your back yep should have killed
that kid sorry oh boy God and I love the two of
them like and even the way that turns around like
immediately because they're talking about like I
don't know who we're gonna lie ourselves with and
the second he gets in that room he's like well
yeah I'm gonna die a treason if I say anything
else but also yeah the scene when I the scene
when uh Damon uh uh has is arguing with rhaenera
and he chokes her that's a hell of a turning point
that's that's like that's HBO right there that's
it it's not TV you can't have it's HBO can't
have HBO if you're male leading actors not
every pitch begins with that Mark of a good HBO
show right there every HBO story is just about how
we got to the moment when some of the male leads
the male lead becomes domestically violent that's
that's when you know you're watching HBO show
welcome back to the domestic violence Network
um no that that is the turning point
though for sure I think I think the
the thing that was kind of baffling to me is I
thought they said some statement about like no
don't worry we cut back on like the harming of
women and there's only like really like Runner
is like really hurt a lot in this I think they
that that like if I didn't hear that I think
I don't think I would have thought of that I
mean obviously not um I think they meant they
cut down on on a the amount of gratuitous brought
those scenes and then B how many of those things
escalate toward violence got it got it got it
got it okay yeah I think it's more like no this
is still a cruel world for women yeah you know
yeah it's cruel for everyone um yeah so but that
but that moment what I thought was neat about
it was because rhaenera doesn't is not really
fighting him she's not even struggling like to
really like it's not like hitting him or whatever
she's like using the moment to listen to him
and and observe what he's saying yeah so when
he's done choking her she flips it on her
like you have no idea what I'm talking about
he didn't see you he didn't really see you as
a viable successor yeah like never did oh wow
he really did believe in me yeah yeah that's
what I think I thought that was neat I mean
I I feel like you know there's there's some
subjects here within this episode alone that
I'm like as as a guy I have my opinion of
from observing but I'm sure like on a on a
woman's perspective it could be very different
how some of these scenes are received you know
so yeah uh I thought the the
final it was really obvious
like I didn't we didn't read the book
it's really obvious to freaking just uh
like the second he shows up and and it's just a
horror movies stormy night you're just like okay
they're definitely dead uh it was still a really
tense moment and I thought it was beautiful like I
don't recall Game of Thrones even doing a dragon
scene of that like when would they have that uh
like a this dragon writing through the night and
that is and it's like medieval fantasy landscape
like it was gorgeous to look at and was intense
and there was that part of me that was like I
hope not um and then like the reveal of agar like
riding above them in the clouds it was terrifying
like there's terrifying I felt bad for the kid I
felt like he was going to die the second they were
like don't kill anyone just message me yes I mean
not that that's as much like there's a part of
me that thinks part of that maneuver was a little
bit silly honestly because it's like you're you're
sending them into the lines then yeah they're
showing up a [__] Dragon too you know you're
literally sending them to people you know have
since broken their oath and are just expecting
that it will be fine wasn't it just yesterday when
Eamon was ready to like kick your kid's ass and
what's to say like the second he shows up at the
end and vegar Rears her head like you're like oh
yeah well of course they would have people around
here they're the their the the source of all power
right now in the in the realm so like they would
have people probably wherever all their allies are
because they would expect be expect like I think
she would I think it would be reasonable to expect
that uh someone like reniro would know that there
would probably be occupation or you know soldiers
or something from the crown wherever she's going
to send these people because if their allegiance
is in question of course they're they're going
to know that too and want to solidify it you know
yeah no I mean apparently it happens in the book
but I think the I mean just a day so that's not
on the show so that's not a problem so yeah take
that video message you know how smart are you now
book JK the thing is you know what though the
thing a while ago I was listening to something
and and and you know the the critics said
basically like the instead of reading a book
and then watching a movie what he likes to do
instead is do what the other the opposite way
around and and this experience and then hearing
not so much like with the end of The Game of
Thrones series because I think that went the way
it did for other reasons but something like this
I have thoroughly enjoyed for all 10 episodes
and have you know like this feels like really
gripping High Caliber event TV still for me and
it also still gets me excited for the idea of
diving into the book at some point you know and
and and seeing the level of detail change and
and all of that the expansive experience
won't do it no not until the show's over
no well yeah I mean that's yeah for an ongoing
experience like this yeah I don't I don't want
to spoil anything that might be rearranged
out of context but it does make me curious
messages would be cool to catch Easter eggs in
the moment and stuff and then be like here's what
they changed and here's where it's gonna lead
to or maybe not now they can't be there yeah
yeah I I like not knowing um yeah absolutely
especially when seeing how upsetting it is
I was like quite liked it I will say that
generally this show has been every episode
has gotten like a better for me okay
it started off great and it just kept
getting greater and greater and greater
and this was the first time I was like
not greater like this is not my favorite like like
every new episode was becoming like oh that's a
contender for favorite episode like that's the
way it was sort of going for me but this one
um definitely like there were there were some
some stuff about the last episode that made me go
I'm not sure so great this sort of felt like
the last and first episode of a season to me
in in a sense yeah yeah I felt like they were
really trying to wrap a lot up yeah and I was
like why are we rapping stuff like we're just set
up yeah absolutely because I think you could still
end on the same kind of note without having
to wrap all that stuff up and leave some of
that for later when we can expand on it yeah
if it was there am I giving you reminders of
when people try to wrap a series up well I'm
like we're not wrapping up a series wrapping
up a season right now but you're also you're
leaving it open to continue it for next season so
it's it's not like you have to end it in a way
of we might not come back so you know we'll wrap
it all like that's not what you're doing so
some stuff I thought was like no let's deal
with like the they just saw this series yeah
let's have the craving moments they just lost
a baby like let's deal with this let's let's go
into the conversations it's been a it's been one
of the best parts about this show and they do
take the time to have those conversations for
a show that I feel like has mastered time jump
they weirdly skip over a lot of it seems like
very important things to to deal with with
our characters that seem to be kind of like
this happens oh I'm sad moving on as opposed to
something looming you know yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah and I think that I I guess I would agree with
that assessment yeah that like I like this episode
a lot a lot of things about it it wouldn't be yeah
that continuous rise and and partly because I feel
like another thing that has made the show so good
on top of the grip on time jumping is the balance
between again the the big world political stakes
and the small personal Stakes the weight of the
crown and all of its Pursuits and this episode
felt like it zoomed out more than it zoomed in
and it left a lot of the zoomed in stuff
I agree with that yeah in the performances
so luckily you have Emma DARS and you have Matt
Smith and people who can carry that around with
them but yeah I feel like the writing didn't
do such a good job at balancing the two here
but uh for this one was cool I always love toilets
I don't remember what happened well and two it's I
think it is interesting and I would love to hear
more opinions about the fact that like I feel
like the show has been marked like you pointed out
there's the bookends of the birth with you know uh
uh uh raniera's mother uh uh you know in the early
you know the first episode and then in the middle
you get not only a a raniera birth but you also
get Lena and that whole thing and then you get
this and uh and and and two like the whole Lane
of thing not that it's like directly tied to this
but there is a very heavy Dragon element there
so it's like there there are these interesting
symmetries and these interesting you know themes
they've peppered throughout yeah I'm not sure the
purpose of it other than the I mean it's like the
Symmetry is obvious yeah because I mean obviously
correlate it it's like first one is renera's Mom
viserys dealing with this uh that's like really
tied to radera and then because that person could
have been the boy right yeah the the King for a
Day there for a day right so got his own funeral
pyre that was uh more linked to Rainer and then
the next one was more linked to Damon and then now
this is about both of them yeah you know so it's
like yeah one two three commas this is the true
like it's the trilogy I wanted well and then two
you have the the one right near a birth which is
like a weird display of strength where she's like
damn it I'm marching in Dallas this film with my
baby and here it's oh yeah there's at Birth too
yeah yeah yeah and then here you flip that around
where it's like no one I am doing this alone and
I'm doing it on my terms and and and yeah it's
like a much more sickly kind of gollumy moment
in a way so it's like it's never before have I
seen his season so marked by traumatic birthing
scenes well I think this episode's um pulse was
interesting like it was a bit weird like a bit
Lucid at times sometimes very uh sometimes felt
very like definitely focused on the immediate
moment but I think it was there were there were
some shortcomings in the season wrap-up syndrome
um and I because because there was plenty
of times where I was like man this is really
intense just I'm gearing up and learning
information and getting ready to go like
this is intense I'm so craving pizza right now by
the way like this is so weird this is so intense
um you said a flash of Pizza House pepperoni wow
I could see the crusted the cheese is she's here
and I just felt and screaming come over in my oven
yeah but it was it was it was good it was it was a
good one um I I I I liked it I liked it a lot
it was a different it was very different than
the other ones and I think sometimes because
they didn't have I got the impression that
sometimes they didn't have enough run time to do
the dialogue scenes so they would try to really
make up for it with like mood and atmosphere and
tone and like The Grieving scenes like just really
no no one talked just really show it you know
and to be fair to a degree it is a time for for
you know Stone silence and reflective silence so
I don't begrudge the episode those tones either
and auto man he shows up man what a dick
every time well now more than ever Jesus
master plan has come to fruition he
is like all about himself right now
Mr Coffee yeah no if there's anyone I want to
see die it's him horribly I love watching him
but he's also the one I'm like man you show up
and just you talk like you're so pompous you're
so arrogant I just want you to die like smug is
the word yeah you're a smug [__] seldom have I
experienced a character where like when he when
he gets you know he relieved the first time of
being hand and they send him away rarest Decades
of Mormon damn I'm kind of sad to see him go and
then the second he shows back up I'm like I hope
someone kills him yeah but he showed up here I was
like just go for it yeah just kill him you know
what's coming you know what's gonna happen yeah
yeah yeah I'm also I'm curious to to see how this
sits with me and how part of me thinks it's cool
that they ended the season on here's one episode
only from one perspective and one episode only
from the other and part of me wonders if there
could be some kind of maybe lacking Symmetry and
that we should have some kind of I don't know
side by side at the very end but I don't know
I thought it was kind of a unique Choice given
how much each episode is usually shown you a bit
of everything which I think I think doing that
really helps establish the Divide yeah yeah of
Team Green versus Team blacks I I think that that
was a great choice damn you were saying something
no no I don't think I really needed them to
come back around to say anything including
both sides like I think I think you're probably
yeah it's like you leave us off with just how
bad things have gotten at home in the last one
and then this one it's yeah here's here is the
fight for next season and here is you know from
our main perspective from Rainier's perspective
you know what is to come I think you know like
Eamonn having like vague like Eric's accidentally
attacked like Eric's out of um luceris's control
attacking didn't bother me um vegar attacking out
of eamon's control didn't bother me it was only
when I heard why I bothered people that I was like
oh yeah I guess that would have been a stronger
Choice see in the moment I was at the moment I
didn't I didn't mind I was like oh [__] that's
terrible and even though they're both you know
Dragon Riders to different degrees you know how
can in control are they really their kids to some
degree still you know so in that moment I bought
it for those various reasons so then yeah yeah
but when hearing that I like I like the choice
more of Amen was like uh Eamonn if Eamon was
um it it is stronger to me if aemond is as opposed
to like ah great another another mistake he's just
upgrade it yeah another mistake that's gonna
either make this character try and get more
sentimental or just become much worse because I
still feel like to me it doesn't undercut that
Eamonn made a mistake still that this is
still eamon's mistake he's still the one
who chose to like relentlessly pursue this
guy out in this weather but then ride that
dragon and he was like see the whole time I
thought he was trying to kill him yeah so like
um you know as opposed to just get the eye it the
whole time I was convinced he was just trying to
kill him okay and so this is still his fault
you know like because like he oh he can't walk
away going it's not my fault he's like you
can't walk away say that even though it was
vegar who didn't listen to him you can't say
that because I'm like well you gotta pushed it
to this point man yeah you invited this 100
I'm sure Vegas probably only the impression
that doesn't support his job was you wanted
that kid to believe he was about to die and
probably his dragon as well so what do you
expect yeah yeah I still I still felt like
it was his it was his fault regardless not like
he's not he's not revoked of responsibility like
I still feel like no he's pretty much
like 99.9 responsible for what happened
so I think that's why like I like the choice of
him just going headstrong into it um but you know
if he tries to like do a whole episode of like
copying out of it like it was an accident which
I don't think I don't see him it almost seems like
in this world Eamon would just be like uh yeah I
killed him yeah I guess I did yeah sure you know
he should have just let me take the eye it's his
fault you should have just let me exact my equal
revenge and that's it instead he got himself eight
and and burned up all right
guys well House of dragon
you know it's like I think the thing that has me
worried is that the the show's been so positively
received yeah and then when this leaked it was
like oh my God the book readers are all like
pissed off yeah yeah yeah yeah they would be the
ones who were like no no I don't care about the
viewing experience I've got to go right in and see
what this is I think I don't wanna I don't want to
do this again we've all been enjoying it please
please I know there's some who don't just let us
but it seem like everyone was happy let us have
one satisfying finale I can't do this to my soul
again I know what's season two gonna be like is
it gonna be a disaster no Miguel sapochnic maybe
it is a bigger deal uh alrighty I hope it it's I
hope it's good maybe they'll take some some notes
from the internet we'll see you guys thanks
for being here much love see you in two years